I I know that if I sign one of these
deals with any one of these networks
they would have said something like you
know we don't think you should have Milo
on because the current advertisers
that's exactly how it plays out yeah
no become a member at timcast.com I mean
you're totally right about that I mean
that's the that's the reason that like
I'm you know you asked me a moment ago
or what's you know have you worked on a
movie since plot against the president
answer is no I'm building a company the
reason I'm building this company is
because I need a place where the
conservative
documentary and you know I'm working on
a couple of scripteds but that's just my
thing
um where the conservative world that's
going to do documentaries that would
normally just font would crowdfund them
and just put them out on YouTube or put
them up for free on whatever
um that's their only way of getting
around the censorship is to not make
money but that's not an industry we're
not going to beat Hollywood without
being an industry